this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah get a standard Frank it's uh
episode 11. it goes fast episode 11 of
the church show this year in our fourth
season so we're more than halfway yeah
more than halfway okay so a great uh a
morning shot from uh Jim pavanetti uh at
um
Fairview Fairview sorry that's right I
was going to say I was going to say
Fairway and it's like Fairview right and
Jimmy Jim's done a great bunch of work
on the golf course a lot of renovation
stuff really talks about the bmps that
they've included uh in this so always
like uh sharing an early morning picture
but you know today Carl we're going to
get talking about some things we don't
always talk about and a lot of it was
spurred by last week some of the things
Rich Buckley said to us about what's
going on early season now notice isn't a
good picture I took it off of a
equipment technician's Twitter feed and
this is a bunch of uh pieces of paper
that you use to check sharpness on the
mower with a magnet on it so you can
stick it in different places when you're
working so that you're not trying to
pull it out of your pocket or grab it
from somewhere else this is you know a
little simple equipment technician hack
because really you know we don't talk
about this a lot but these are really
important people on golf courses right I
mean I actually think if you put
superintendents you know on on a hot
seat once in a while and say hey who do
you want an assistant or a good
equipment manager I think they'd
probably take not that anything against
good solid assistance but setner reel
and setting these units up is so
important to the overall performance of
the golf course now rich said to us last
week that early season anthracnosis is
picking up now you know this only has
one cause that we are stressing these
plants they they went into the winter
stress
and they're coming out of the winter
stress and remember early on Carl we
said there wasn't any winner which means
a lot of places have had a lot of play
and the combination of you know early
season play some already stressed grass
is probably setting you up for if you're
getting it now it's going to be a long
season because you know I've been
barking that gossip here things don't
look good now this conditions are ideal
in some ways unless you're under a lot
of stress now thinking about anthracnose
and mowing thinking about intactos and
traffic the research is pretty clear
that top dressing uh to protect the
crowns of annual Bluegrass is really
critical John inguinal's work there's
been some follow-up work on amounts of
sand and timing of sand and spring
timing of sand growth of sand to really
get in there and protect that canopy is
really critical right if you're getting
out of the gate now with some rain
coming you're a little bit soft right
you got the mower set maybe a little
aggressive because there's a lot of
grass there and you want to get it off
once you start doing that you better
have some sand there to protect those
crowns and prevent anthracials right
because again antarctos is one of those
diseases that you know starts foliar and
then if stress continues it will become
you know basil rot and then once you rot
the crown you know you're done you're
just going to sit there and watch it
look bad for a while because the plant
has no ability to regenerate tissue and
since we're talking about mowing Brian
Whitlock and John Daniels wrote a paper
in the USGA green section A number of
years ago that talked about the bed
knife position on a on a mower behind
the center line of the Reel as soon as
you start to move that bed knife
position back now sometimes that happens
because you grind your reel so much the
diameter of the Reel starts to shrink
when that happens the only way to get
the geometry and the reel to work right
is to bring the bed knife angle up and
back so you're moving it back which is
allowing the reel to tip into the canopy
right more aggressively and do some
raking so you see here uh you know in
this particular thing we're at the same
height of cut but the behind Center
distance in one of the uh pictures
brings you uh closer into the canopy
you're getting actually below the mowing
height depth because the real is Snip is
getting into the canopy and raking it
out so the further the bed knife is back
in the Reel the more that reel is
pitched into the canopy the more it's
slapping and whacking that tissue and
adding to some stress and even cutting a
little bit lower now mower manufacturers
set these things out of the out of the
shop different I would check them them
when you get them not like everybody's
getting a bunch of new mowers these days
they can't get them built but when they
can get them built this is the one area
where the John Deere uh putting green
mowers have the ability to get that
um bed knife closer to the center
distance it comes not as far behind the
center distance it gives you a little
bit more flexibility now what is the
value of this again we've talked about
this before when you get behind too far
the more aggressive bed knife angle that
tips behind you're tipping into the
canopy more which means you're adding
more stress we've played around with
this many years ago I think I've done
this work I think some of this work is
15 16 years old now where we set five
mowers up uh Flex 21s with the bed knife
at different positions now it took us a
while in Upstate New York to get
anthracnose but when we did have a final
really get an anthracnose outbreak we
saw a very linear response in August and
September that when it was dry and it
was still warm back in these years and
we had the more aggressive setting we
were getting more anthracnose the more
aggressive the mower was set up and we
did this all year on an annual Bluegrass
bent grass surface now
John sorakin Tom Nikolai Aaron Hathaway
many years ago with Corey ursic at
Michigan State took this work we started
and went a little bit further looking at
behind Center distance the impact on
clipping collection and sand collection
so in very simple terms the further back
your bed knife is the more sand you're
gonna pick up so if we're telling you to
top dress right and we're telling you
that's going to help you with
anthracnose uh but your bed knife is too
far behind the center distance you're
going to be harvesting more sand so this
is again where some people pivot to a
John Deere machine other people go and
change the bed knife behind Center
distance now what's interesting here is
green speed didn't change and clipping
production clipping yield didn't change
so if you think you're being more
aggressive to get faster greens or you
think think you're being more aggressive
to get more clippings and make faster
greens the research does not bear out
that's what's happening so listen Carl
this has been an early start and talk to
bench benchmarking our mowers but I know
you've got enough you know the bench
Heights and the things we said on the
bench you've got another look at
benchmarking that is really interesting
looking at the operation as a whole and
some of our successes in our state park
program take it away yeah I think Frank
you know it makes a whole lot of sense
with mower setups when you can put
specific numbers to behind Center
distance uh you know that stuff with
John Daniels the USGA one said you know
it's a 26 difference in height of cut so
I could say oh okay you know if I was
setting it at 125 with my behind Center
distance was way off I was actually
cutting at .093 so that was some of the
calculations I was doing like hey I
thought I was cutting a 125 oh my God
I'm under 100.
um it's really good to have that
benchmarking stuff and those actual
numbers years to compare okay heck now I
can measure behind Center distance on my
reels how do I compare right uh with
some of our our agronomic practices uh I
think we lack some of that data right so
the idea behind benchmarking is really
just having some way to evaluate or
check ourselves relative to some
industry standard
um and so like you know I showed data
last week on John ROM and these PGA Tour
guys you hear Strokes game talked about
all the time that's their benchmarking
tool right I know John ROM is 2.4
Strokes better than the average tour pro
right that's how he's so good and he
gets there by being X Strokes better per
round and approach or driving and
cutting but that's their benchmarking
standard uh some of the benchmarking
things we have maybe we don't have quite
as much data for that and some of our
agronomic practices
um Doug Lindy has worked a lot down in
Delaware trying to Benchmark uh Golf
Course practices and maybe some of their
resources that they have available to
produce playing conditions this is some
data from back in New Zealand when he
was doing this in the early 2000s
basically went around a bunch of golf
courses he asked him hey what's your
Revenue
um how how big is your green staff
what's your cutting height and then he
surveyed sort of just weed populations
in the fairways and not surprisingly the
courses that have higher Revenue have
higher green staff they have lower
cutting Heights right because they can
maintain that and they have less weeds
so when I look at this as a golf course
maybe where I'm looking at and trying to
find usefulness is where do I fit in
right where's my sort of Bin you know
and when we think about Labor is a huge
it's a huge deal having the necessary
labor to produce claim conditions you
know I was finding some of this data
from the gcsaa from last year's capital
budget and labor survey okay what's
what's the general uh full-time FTE
equivalents in the high Seasons if you
have one to five ftes in High season
you're actually in the bottom quartile
of golf courses in the US right so
that's uh good to know right and if
you're a golf course manager of your GM
your Your Greens committees are
expecting really high conditions and
you're sort of in the bottom half or
bottom quartile of Labor hey maybe
that's one thing you can use to to say
okay I actually need two more people I
need 11 to be in that top 30 and that
might get us around the cutting Fairways
more often keeping up with the rough
being able to top dress every two weeks
to get out of infrasto so you just
mentioned that right Frank
um so we've tried to do some of this
with our state parks and maybe some
non-traditional metrics pesticide use uh
and pesticide risk I know that's maybe
sort of a taboo term saying the term
pesticide risk
um but that's what we do with our state
park courses we work with about 15 for
over a decade now and what we've done is
we have a state average for those
watching the the black line is the state
average of all those 15 courses this is
measured using the eiq we've got
different regions right we've got
courses in Long Island that's the yellow
bar up top Upstate in blue you know
Hudson Valley Albany and gray what we've
looked at over the years is hey which
courses use more right okay Long Island
courses uh especially back in the mid
sort of 20 teens used a lot more
pesticides and it's not about like hey
you got to use less it's okay why is
that the case uh it's probably extended
growing Seasons right they have a longer
growing season they have higher pest
pressure we've measured this now through
some of our disease models on the
forecast website there's also quality
expectations right so Bethpage State
Park has high high expectations Montauk
Downs right the golfers down there
expect a little bit more that drives
resources up
um so it's understanding here's why
you're above average and similarly with
Upstate courses hey here's why you're
below average and you see actually over
the years we're sort of seeing all those
regions sort of come together a little
bit more in the data especially the last
five or six years and a lot of that has
been them figuring out okay here's where
I can reduce and hey I'm still getting
the quality and now we've got data Frank
from
um from some courses Across the Nation
we've got an average now that that we
look at you know 260 in this metric not
that that means anything to anybody but
260 is the national average our State
courses are under 100 on average so
that's good to say hey we've worked at
them a lot on pesticide risk and trying
to reduce that and hey it's good to know
that that we're below the national
averages
and so we we do this with fertilizer use
as well so we can look at the gcsaa data
again is a good way to Benchmark some
resources on golf courses we've got the
Northeast courses from that recent data
on the left our state park courses on
the right right we use less fertilizer
the goal is not to use way way less than
them it's just to sort of figure out hey
here's why we're here's where we're in
the ballpark okay we're half a pound
Less on Fairways and our goal is
actually to figure out what's the least
we can do while maintaining those
playing conditions and and what we've
seen in the last couple years with
increased traffic especially on teas and
Fairways is hey maybe we're pushing the
bottom level of that and maybe we
actually need to come back up and get
closer to those Regional averages right
and there's probably a reason why
they're they're Regional averages is
they probably work pretty good yeah um
so using that as a sort of context and
that's why I put this quote up on the
screen context is Clarity sort of
figuring out you know when you can have
these benchmarking numbers I think it's
nice to sort of get the lay of the land
right I've had a picture of the land at
Dinsmore which is a really cool old golf
course down in Hudson Valley and the
idea is not necessarily to be the best
right I mentioned John Robb and PGA Tour
guys they're trying to be the best of
the world with golf courses right you're
not resourced uh to be the best for
every golf course and you're really just
trying to figure out where you fit in
right it's it's about fitting in and
again with our state park where we we
try and figure out hey where do we fit
in in the local golf community so this
is when we pull data from our friends at
pellucid right we look at the facilities
that are around each golf course here's
some data from Chenango Valley so rural
Upstate New York and when we look at the
courses around them they sort of they
tend to be stratified in the what we
call public medium public low price
points right so a lot of the golfers in
that area
you know they're not demanding high-end
Public Health they're just demanding
Affordable Golf and and that gives us
some information about how we want to
maintain the property hey maybe they
don't need perfectly manicured uh
Fairways they don't need to have the
rust fertilized they just care about the
greens right so it gives us some
information on how we want to manage and
then you go to a place like Bethpage
right and 65 of the courses within I
think this is five kilometers or ten
kilometers at Bethpage they're private
right so you're going to have a higher
end audience they're expecting you know
well manicured Fairways tightly mowed
right 100 Turf quality real dense nice
ball a lot
um so trying to figure out benchmarking
not only in our resource use but hey
what do our golfers expect from us
um and trying to work backwards from
that so I keep talking I talked about
this with Mike Valens a couple weeks ago
I was sort of measuring these outcomes
that's why I like benchmarking Frank it
gives you that sort of that bar that
that you can be around okay can I be a
little bit below can I be a little bit
above
um I think that's really useful and can
help track decision making yeah and I
gotta tell you Carl you know you
everybody's heard especially as long as
we've been doing the show right we
started it during covet and so we lost a
lot of Labor I mean we weren't sure we
could work when I look back at some of
those talks we didn't know if we could
work a lot of people said wow
I'm actually getting a lot done with our
golfers here or wow I'm actually getting
I I didn't do that and it doesn't seem
to matter right and I think sometimes we
we we
internalize I gotta do more with less
right and the reality is I think to your
point about the bottoming out maybe of
the nitrogen when I see that six 58 of
the golf courses in America have less
than 10 people full time at peak season
uh that means we're already I think uh
operating at a pretty high efficiency if
you just go to less than 15 you've got
three quarters of the golf courses in
America have less than 15 people at you
know a full season now full season in
the desert and the south is different
than you know full you know peak season
in the north but I think Carl this is a
very interesting number one piece of
data to look at Labor because as you
said if I got more guys that means I got
more hands for weed whackers or around
the trees I can rake the bunkers three
times a week for us just once a week and
I think really good golf course
superintendents do talk to the people
about these kinds of things and even One
Step better when you get into corporate
Golf and you go to Troon or you go to
Kemper properties they got this dialed
in they don't spend a dime more than
they have to relative to the results
they're going to get the return on that
investment right with a higher round of
golf you know paying more for around the
golf right Dynamic pricing when the
demand goes up you got a nice place
you're getting more money you better
have the resources and my sense is those
places are not afraid to spend that
money Carl and it seems to pay off in
the markets they're in anything you want
to wrap up here since I added some color
ready to move on
uh yeah I'll just comment Frank that
that those bigger organizations because
they're looking at the bottom line a lot
more they have that information on hey
if we buy another pallet of x uh where
does that get us in return on investment
right and
um I I think probably a lot of the
individual courses that are privately
owned or owned by a group of members
maybe don't look at that quite enough
and uh that's that's like 101 running
businesses right big corporations that's
what they're doing right so just a
comment that I think that's that sort of
standardized data is is probably
important to have okay well speaking of
benchmarking let's look at where the
temperatures were last week and it was a
cooler week right after 20 degrees but
above normal like I said normal or a
little bit below normal is going to feel
cold and in fact it really did you and
essentially we've hit a bit of a stall
here in many parts of the Northeast uh
from a temperature perspective we were
talking about it on the conference call
this morning and it has this weird
feeling to it the growing season the
numbers say we're ahead even collecting
since March 15th not grabbing that heat
at the end of February or much of the
warm winter we're saying since March
15th we're close to two weeks ahead at
least a week to two weeks ahead but and
you see it in the forsythians they're
done in many areas in upstate New York
and I'm not seeing crabgrass anywhere
we're going to chat with Matt Elmore
tomorrow on the grounds episode of the
turf show and talk of course more in
depth about that now it was actually
relatively good rainfall wise just about
everybody got a half an inch a lot of
people got an inch or more and a bunch
of people got three and four inches
through the Connecticut Valley uh out by
stores Connecticut tons of rain but then
as you get out to the East End out to
the cape and the islands out there Long
Island much less rainfall less than a
half an inch in those areas but overall
uh we're expecting more rainfall coming
and some cooler temperatures so cooler
temperatures uh below normal
temperatures right instead of being in
the mid 50s we're going to be in the low
50s to upper 40s
um and and rainfall is going to come
through again Friday Saturday looks like
a big hit and then it's sort of cloudy
and rainy for the next week I think art
described it as you know good weather
for a duck uh moving folks now one of
the things we we have heard about is
another one of these early spring
diseases and this is where we're getting
all screwed up it's like man I think I'm
ahead but whoa I got pink snowmo uh oh I
think I'm ahead oh I got YT a patch oh I
think I'm ahead I got early season
anthracnose these sorts of problems
really start to wreak havoc and make you
question some of the things that you're
doing there's a lot of products
available for whiteia patch this is a
rhizoctonia organism so anything that
works well on the rhizox is pretty
pretty good I will put a plug in for
polyoxin D which is a firm or endorse
that's a really good rhizoc product it
actually has that sort of Niche area so
if you have a yellow patch if the
conditions are going to be conducive
this typically is considered a cosmetic
problem but if conditions persist you
will get pitting and and depressions in
the Rings from this organism so again
you know early season problems that we
don't don't often worry about because we
think we're going to get growth on the
other side looks like those problems are
getting worse rainfall comes I wanted to
put even even though I got some crappy
pictures here I saw some collar damn
work going on a lot of times uh collars
start to build up in their height and
and and get higher build up either the
green you know they're getting top
dressed differently they're getting not
rolled as much and you get these collar
dams in certain places that hold water
on a green and if especially if it's in
a low spot on a green this adds to a lot
of problems so getting in there side
cutting taking it out a good simple
thing to help your cleanup passes
survive the growing season ahead is
getting the water off of there now the
soil temperatures you know we were
talking 50s and 60s last week and now
we're talking well and they Adirondacks
in the 30s but in the 40s through much
of the reason and even just the 50s are
confined to just along the coast and
further south by Virginia when you got
to go to Virginia now to get 55 degrees
at two inches so again if you were
running out there early because you saw
the warm temperatures and you made your
applications early you're going to sit
there and stare at that for a couple of
weeks and that might be a wasted
herbicide or fertilizer application with
the conditions we're under right now so
let's get back to the anthracnose thing
because once we start talking about
growth now we're stock talking about the
inability to keep up with the traffic
and stuff that you're doing last week we
talked about stress Carl and we said hey
you know stress your plants you can dry
them out a little bit and I think you
and I were corrected pretty quickly by
Dr Buckley who said whoa that's assuming
you got plants that can do those things
so when you start thinking about
intentionally imposing stress on your
playing surfaces there are coarse
enormous numbers of benefits you get
from the variety of ways we can impose
stress from mowing lower and vertic
cutting and rolling to to moisture
stress like we talked about last week
now when we think about imposing stress
on annual Bluegrass which is just
getting going now right we know that
it's coming into that time where seed
head production is going to be at Peak
now when that happens a lot of the
resources that plant used to use for
vegetative growth and root growth stops
so you know that plant is triggered now
to produce that flowering stalk that is
the end as soon as that plant produces
that flowering stock and and you mow it
off that tiller is dead so you get this
natural waning period on the other side
of a seed head flush that I think we got
to be careful on putting the stress on
the other thing I'm starting to see just
like we predicted is a lot of over
regulation right if you're not tracking
your growth and you're saying wow it's
the end of April it was just warm I'm
getting buckets like crazy let me go out
with my proxy Primo boy it seems like
it's growing let me get the raid up boom
and now you're over regulated because
it's cold you're over regulating because
you got too much traffic so you're just
not able to grow so let's remind
everybody the great work that our
colleagues at Rutgers have done in
elucidating the impact of a variety of
practices on basal Rod anthracnose and
what they concluded clearly was you can
molo you can roll you can get fast
greens but you better feed those things
because as soon as you start skimping on
nitrogen the amount of basal rot
anthracnose that you see in that stand
goes up exponentially in some cases you
really start to see that surge when
growth rate is dropping off so nitrogen
at this time if it will respond to it
will certainly give you some benefits
now you got to remember if we're
averaging temperatures 55 degrees the
cool season grass growth potentials only
have 40 percent so you're not even
operating at full vibration yet in your
plants growing and you're beating the
hell out of them and you're top dressing
them and you're playing golf on them
like crazy and the temperature is not on
your side and you got over regulation
and you got traffic and you're wondering
why we got some of these early season
problems let's just remind everybody
that when we say low nitrogen we mean
you know below three pounds of end once
you get from three to six pounds we call
that high nitrogen but it's not not high
nitrogen for the actual growth of a
grass plant you can put up to 16 pounds
of end per thousand per year before you
max out clipping production so we are
purposely keeping these plants in a
nitrogen starved condition right
nitrogen is not as prevalent in the
environment other than in the atmosphere
so to plants it's a limiting nutrient so
we have been taught to limit this
nutrient but we've also been taught that
we don't want to get you know two out of
whack here because it leads to
anthracnose now the other thing we've
learned about growth rate is the higher
you mow the slower it grows hunting
greens grow more rapidly than collars
that are a little bit higher and right
next door and so consequently growth
Regulators applied at the same rates and
frequencies over these two surfaces will
over regulate the collars and then guess
what else we do to the collars we turn
the mowers on the car I don't care how
many flat pieces of fence you put there
it's still putting traffic and wear and
tear in those things so growth rate is
really impacted now now
I dug this up from 40 years ago Clark
Russell's been retired now for a number
of years when he did his PhD at Penn
State in 1981 he looked at the effect of
cutting height and nitrogen rate on
green speed on ball roll distance he
mowed a tenth of an inch and 3 16 or 187
187 thousandths of an inch right and he
went from one pound of n to six pounds
of it
he got a green speed at a tenth of an
inch at two pounds of end that was a
little bit uh right at 10 feet
when he went up to six pounds event that
green speed only went down six inches
now
we're not doing see the same things we
did 40 years ago but we're trying to
make the point that if you're struggling
with a lot of these things that are
impacted by low growth rate don't be
afraid to add some nitrogen in small
amounts you don't want to add like oh a
half a pound of granular but maybe a
tenth of a pound two tenths of a pound
if you're normally a tenth of a pound
maybe two tenths of a pound might be
good to go in this early season to get
it going now we've learned from Doug
Soul that's work and Bill's work at
Wisconsin that traffic reduces growth
when you have traffic you're not getting
as much top growth right that is having
a big impact on it now the last part of
this Carl is green speed so you get
traffic and you want fast green Scott
and Ivan wrote this article in the tea
to Green the Met superintendent's Tita
green a couple of years ago escalating
green speeds and Todd Quint Quint no
just wrote another article in the most
recent version of the Teeter green uh
from an architect's perspective he
attended a conference out in New England
with a bunch of Architects and did some
survey work and first off in the first
article by Scott Niven he was listing
the medium speed in the metropolitan New
York area based on a on a survey was 11
feet 3 inches a slow green was about 10
feet 9 feet 9 inches and a fast green
was considered 12 feet 6 inches based on
a survey of the Metropolitan
superintendents now just a reminder
Scott mingay one of the research
managers at the USGA involved with the
development of the GI S3 they did a GPS
study a while ago looking at various
green speeds and the actual amount of
time that it took to play so when you
start getting above 10 and a half feet
on green speeds you're looking at about
25 to 30 minute increases in the time it
takes to play around the golf or at
least two minutes per putting surface
based on the uh how the time it takes to
play a you know play around the golf now
my question is is the stress worth it
all the time right so that survey that
Todd quitno did asked a bunch of
Architects when you're designing a green
complex how do you prioritize the
following elements of green design and
they asked them to select the top five
the first two by far were pinnable area
and drainage functional performance the
next one was blending into surroundings
the next one was size and area and
putability likely uh green speed so it
looks like paintable area and drainage
two things we care about are on
Architects Minds asking those Architects
for ideal green speed at least 52
percent of them said 10 to 11 feet an
interesting full third said nine to ten
feet now you take this in contrast with
what superintendents say and you begin
to get at the root of some of this
problem and this is really going to
drive everybody crazy who drives the bus
on green speeds when you asked
Architects stay true to superintendents
right under the bus 44 of the architect
said Golf Course superintendents are
driving green speeds and third followed
closely by Green committees at 38
percent right at 38 and then the golfers
themselves or governing bodies are less
than 10 percent so you can see the big
impact that design is having now Carl as
I wrap it up
um here's another little piece from
Todd's article easy locator has the
ability to determine pinnable air areas
based on the size of your putting
surface the slope of the green and the
speed of the green so here's a little
exercise where they looked at the same
putting surface at three different green
speeds at seven feet green speed which
is presumably really low 75 percent of
that putting surface is available for
pins for a couple locations as soon as
you go to 10 feet now you're down to 40
percent and when you go to 12 feet
you've got essentially three percent of
that putting surface less the left the
cup now Carl what is the interesting
thing that I know you will comment on
here as we as we wrap it up as we're
over the time go figure we're by
ourselves and we're over the time you
said and showed on our state park golf
courses when we have less area on the
putting surface that drives up our
traffic rate so green speed also
increases Focus traffic to the places
where you can put the whole location
that was an interesting like whoa that
is a big deal so I think as a golfer I
know you like Fast greens but this has
to concern you a little bit yeah exactly
what I was thinking about Frank we've
done some organic matter sampling and
some of the new om-246 stuff from the
top two centimeters and we were finding
that at a golf course the bigger greens
have more organic matter that's because
traffic is more spread out and then you
have smaller greens you know we
mentioned Chenango State Park Larry's
got one green that is literally a fifth
of the size of his other green he's got
the smallest Green in all of the state
park system and the largest screen in
all the state park system and they have
different organic matter rates because
they're different traffic and you look
at those charts from Easy locator you
know when I when I lose 35 percent of my
pinnable area I'm effectively shrinking
that grain and now I'm focusing all that
traffic in those areas uh yeah so
there's probably agronomic issues there
when I think of as a golfer and I talk
to set up people like the nysga they
would rather have some some slower green
speeds because they can utilize more of
the putting surfaces like the architect
intended getting it closer to ridges and
and having some sloped putts uh that are
at least manageable from a golfer's
perspective instead of being stuff
that's going to roll off the green so uh
yeah you know the green speed that's
that's sort of the danger of
benchmarking right Frank is when you get
into green speeds and 11 is considered
medium man 11 is a fast green and like
you said that's going to drive up pace
of play pretty quickly for your average
membership I would think so very very
interesting start to the season with the
starting and stopping and and and and
you know buckets of grass and now you're
staring at it and if you have as we
talked about last week and just to wrap
it up stress greens now it's not going
to get any better unless you make some
adjustments and and I think the final
point is if you are growing getting the
sand in there uh is going to help with
that early season anthracnose as well
now if you're not grown all you're doing
is throwing a sand on top and you set
your mower wrong you're going to pick
most of it up so that's the lesson for
today it looks like we're going to need
a little more patience moving forward
Carl yeah and and so tomorrow we'll have
Matt Almar on from Rutgers and we'll
talk to Matt about hey weed development
where is it at this year uh with this
sort of stop and start uh weather we've
had in the Northeast so we're looking
forward to that we'll probably chat some
crab glass tomorrow uh so everybody will
see you tomorrow for episode 12 uh for
now take care have a good one take care
thanks Carl
foreign
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu